Tiger will these golf clubs be in your
bag when you return to play in December
we'll see no I I still need to do a
little more testing I was getting close
to putting of them in play earlier this
year but unfortunately my back went out
and had a back surgery and then when I
came back I was so limited in what I
could do
practice wise I didn't want to test
anything I still played with my old
stuff this time around I'll have a
little more time to test it out I know
we're really close I was so excited
about the ball flight when we move the
CG out putting a little tungsten my 10
millimeters further out I was excited
and shocked to see the ball flight how
much better went through the wind what
is it for you that determines whether
you're ready to make that change if the
club is better than when I've been using
it's in a bag period that's just slate
as if it's not better than then I put in
the bag how was your back how's my back
right now it's a little bit stiff
sitting and standing in front all day
makes a little bit stiff but it's the
the rehab process you know I got to go
through that again luckily I didn't do
any any damage to it it's no secret
gulps in a bit of trouble you've seen
the same numbers I've seen both of you
have six million fewer people playing
today than back in two thousand courses
closing by the hundreds how does that
change the way Nike looks at all we
actually view what's happening in golf
right now as an opportunity and I say
that because our portfolio of
innovations has never been stronger our
stable of athletes never been more
compelling and we have the power in the
swoosh and while in some parts of the
world golf is certainly going through a
transition in other parts of the world
golf is growing if you look at where
there's a growing middle class you see
golf growing does it matter as much to
Nike that at the very least the North
American market is shrinking given that
you do so well
selling golfing apparel to non golfers
the beauty is we have a portfolio of
products as you mentioned apparel
footwear Club and ball and we're able to
leverage the product portfolio as well
as leverage our geographies
to keep a stable and going business as
we've done in the past few years Tiger I
think you already know that the rise and
fall of golf's growth tracks pretty
closely with the heritage of your career
so beyond the tiger effect how would you
explain the trouble that's golf that
golf is having attracting young people
and and in particularly young men I was
probably at that age when it started
transforming where the advent of the
golf cart really changed the dynamics
you know we had so many of us were
introduced to golf through caddy working
summers and just carrying bags and most
kids now or you know they've got two
cell phones they got 15 batteries and
they're just typing away do all the
different little things and they want
everything instantaneous and one things
now no no no no golf is not like that
well we're trying to get kids that you
know play further forward trying to get
even adults play further forward trying
to make the games faster it's just
different participation is it's it's
hard and we it's it's neat to see other
you know top athletes like say a Michael
Jordan play golf we see Tony Romo a
bunch of the different celebrities even
Steph Curry's got a hell of a game all
these other athletes aren't played play
the game of golf and play it really well
I think that's when you can make golf
cool a lot of people say golf needs a
savior another Tiger Woods if there
isn't and there isn't somebody who has
the same extraordinary record that he
had as a young man and then there's a
maturing golfer what happens well the
good news is we still have Tiger Woods
and he's still teeing it up and he's got
a lot of Records till the break the
other good news is we've got a great new
generation of young athletes coming
along whether it's a Rory McIlroy and
some of the others out there and you're
seeing that energy come through and you
talk about inspiring that next
generation that's part of how you
inspire that next generation then they
see the style out on the golf course the
energy this this group of new athletes
and then the way you can amplify that to
that generation that's fun that creates
energy that lifts up golf